I'll gonna do some stand-up comedy and
some characters I'm the best
do you guys hear what's happening in the
news all right you guys hear this one do
you guys hear in the news this polar
bear he goes he walked into a bar and
and he goes the bartender he says I'll
have a gin and
[Music]
Hey and the bartender says okay but why
the large pause and the polar bear says
I was born with them but we're having
fun here guys Donald Trump okay let's do
some crowd work you guys having the
happenings with Dave when it come I
wasn't everybody understand
welcome to Conan okay you guys like
impersonations okay a few of you okay
all right this first one is an Al Pacino
in any given Sunday I put you know any
given Sunday
[Applause]
football okay this this next one is a
Tom Cruise enjoying marijuana okay
alright this last one is Johnny Depp and
an audition hello Jonathan Christopher
dub
reading reading for the role in the help
he was kind you is smart you is
important the movie Rango okay I have
one I want unless original character
that I made up um okay so this guy he's
the guy he's on the way to the hospital
because his wife is giving birth to his
firstborn and he's super excited cuz
it's a boy and it's gonna be a son so he
he goes to the hospital and all the way
to the hospital she calls him on a cell
phone and she's yelling because the
contractions are happenings and so he
gets to the parking structure and she's
giving birth I mean he gets a parking
structure and goes to the first level
but no parking second level no parking
and then the third level no parking
so he goes all the way down to the
street I'm by he's driving a big old
truck and on the street there's no
parking spot either except for this one
tiny one and and he's a bad parallel
Parker
so this is that guy a guy is on a way to
the hospital with a cellphone his wife
and she's a giving birth
parking parallel and a big truck into a
small spot and he's black last thing
he's a horse damn and I can't park